[Música]
bienvenidos a ella soy de france 24 el 7
de junio será rogel recuperó su libertad
esta mujer salvadoreña había cumplido
casi un tercio de su condena de 30 años
de prisión por violar la dura
prohibiciones del aborto en su país
sara fue arrestada en octubre de 2012
luego de ir a un hospital con heridas
causadas por lo que ella dijo fue una
caída mientras realizaba tareas
domésticas a sus 22 años fue denunciada
procesada y sentenciada por matar a su
hija por nacer según sus defensores sara
nunca mereció estar en prisión y en
lugar de poder vivir el duelo por la
pérdida de su bebé a los 8 meses de
embarazo fue encarcelada injustamente
esta es la historia
tras 10 años de sufrimiento un respiro
de alegría
i
ella es sara rogel una mujer salvadoreña
condenada a 30 años de cárcel por
homicidio agravado su delito
supuestamente haber abortado tras dar a
luz a un bebé muerto mientras sara
asegura haber perdido a su hija tras una
caída la justicia sostiene que se
practicó voluntariamente un aborto pese
a ser un caso emblemático sara no es la
primera mujer en ser sentenciada en el
salvador por cargos relacionados con el
aborto quiero que se haga justicia en el
país porque así como yo sufrí ese daño
hay muchísima gente de 14 mujeres se
encuentran actualmente encarceladas tras
sufrir emergencias obstétricas
de acuerdo con morena herrera de la
agrupación ciudadana por la
despenalización del aborto
[Música]
de modernidades y mundos financieros
electrónicos llenos
de mujer
en el salvador el aborto está totalmente
prohibido incluso cuando haya un riesgo
para la vida de la madre una
malformación del feto o en caso de
violación las mujeres que buscan
terminar un embarazo deben recurrir a
una red clandestina de médicos que
también se arriesgan a ir a prisión
además del salvador en latinoamérica el
aborto está prohibido sin excepciones en
los códigos penales de honduras
nicaragua república dominicana y haití
por su parte cuba uruguay guayana
guayana francesa puerto rico y argentina
permiten abortar sin condiciones en las
primeras semanas de gestación en el
resto del continente todos los estados
incorporan causales en mayor o menor
medida a la interrupción del embarazo
el salvador tiene una de las leyes de
aborto más severas del mundo y eso
estaba acabando con la vida digna de las
mujeres las emergencias obstétricas son
inmediatamente vistas como criminales es
un país donde hay que tener miedo hasta
estando embarazada y de ahí la historia
de sara rogelio que nos da pie para
conversar con su abogada arriba abigail
cortés navarro quien además es defensora
de derechos humanos y también con la
activista y también defensora morena
herrera bienvenidas ambas a ellas hoy
gracias por su tiempo y voy a comenzar
sin tardanza root cuáles fueron los
argumentos para demostrar en su momento
que sara supuestamente cometió un delito
y como su caso puede ayudar a las
mujeres del salvador
sí muchas gracias muy amable por esta
por este espacio verdad para poder
visibilizar esta problemática que
existen en el salvador verdad el cual
está pues siempre latente porque
mientras existe la penalización absoluta
pues siempre se van a ver sometidas
estas mujeres en condición de
vulnerabilidad en este tema en el caso
de sara los argumentos que estableció la
fiscalía general de la república es que
sara dio un golpe verdad con un objeto
contundente al azules y han nacido sin
embargo no se no se perfiló en la prueba
verdad ese objeto el cual manifestó pues
que daba a entender él
o más bien pues fundamentaba el dolo
verdad por el cual es arabia atentado
verdad y había terminado con la vida
suele ser nacida ese fue el fundamento
por parte de la fiscalía pero sea toda
la prueba que se presentó en el caso de
sara que acreditaba pues que había sido
un accidente en ese sentido
mire es que estos casos están plagados
de irregularidades y ya vamos a
continuar hablando de eso a propósito de
ese procedimiento tan dudoso le quiera
preguntar morena porque los médicos
desconfían tanto varios casos documentan
que llaman a la policía incluso antes de
atender a la mujer que está viviendo una
emergencia obstétrica y que tanto existe
un temor de que estas emergencias
obstétricas puedan ser utilizadas como
una tapadera para las mujeres que desean
abortar y pues no pueden hacerlo
legalmente en el país
mire yo creo que es importante entender
que el personal médico se encuentra bajo
muchas presiones la ley que penaliza el
aborto de forma absoluta se convierte
por una parte en una amenaza a las
mujeres embarazadas sobre todo si son
pobres si viven en comunidades más
alejadas de centros de salud pero
también se convierte en una amenaza para
el personal de salud y en especial para
médicas y médicos ellos reciben presión
para que denuncien a cualquier mujer que
consideren que es sospechosa de haberse
provocado un aborto y hay algunos y
algunas que las denuncian incluso antes
de tener ningún tipo de investigación y
confirmación con la simple sospecha
llaman a la policía o llaman a la
fiscalía
y les denuncian pero lo que está detrás
es la propia protección de no ser
señalados cómplices de un
en cubrir un pelito entonces en los
médicos y médicas son obligadas a no
respetar el secreto profesional el deber
del secreto profesional que tienen con
sus pacientes en la actualidad hay
algunas médicas y médicos que han ido
variando esta posición y han ido
concientizándose de este papel y
nosotras hemos trabajado con
con personal médico pero la mayoría vive
digamos todavía con esta presión y hacen
caso hacen eco de esta presión morena
por eso la tengo que interrumpió un
segundo para que podamos avanzar más en
el tema es que de acuerdo con un informe
de amnistía internacional hasta el año
pasado todavía había 18 mujeres
detenidas por la ley antiaborto y los
casos se relacionan con emergencias
obstétricas las mujeres son llevadas
sistemáticamente a la cárcel en su
momento de mayor vulnerabilidad física y
emocional cuando lo que realmente
necesitan es atención médica y
protección
exactamente o sea a ver y no son todas
las mujeres eso también nosotras
insistimos
son mujeres que cumplen un cierto perfil
de mayor vulnerabilidad jóvenes
viviendo en situación de pobreza con un
digamos con una situación de
vulnerabilidad socioeconómica y en
algunos casos familiar
si de ese tema quería continuar hablando
y en este caso le voy a preguntar a ruth
por qué existe esa denuncia de las
agrupaciones feministas en el salvador
que dicen que la penalización total del
aborto afecta principalmente a las
mujeres que están en una mayor situación
de pobreza y de vulnerabilidad en el
país y que luego tienen que enfrentar
unos procesos judiciales en los que se
dan irregularidades y faltas a las
garantías del debido proceso
sara por ejemplo denunció que se cayó
lavando ropa en una zona rural quedó
inconsciente la llevaron al hospital
hospitales y cuando se despertó nunca le
explicaron qué fue lo que pasó con su
bebé nunca le dieron la oportunidad de
tener el duelo ni siquiera de defenderse
ella dice cuando yo caí en cuenta de lo
que estaba pasando ya me habían privado
de la libertad
así es si realmente casi todas las
mujeres verdad que se han enfrentado a
estos procesos y solamente quizás
aclarar verdad que actualmente todavía
existen 14 mujeres que están privadas de
libertad con condena firme debido a que
tampoco no tuvieron en ese momento una
procuración judicial verdad una
defensoría judicial efectiva la cual
también les permitió a muchas pues les
decían que tenían que aceptar bea para
disminuir la pena sin embargo no pasaba
eso siempre les le les establecía una
pena máxima verdad en caso si fuese
tentado a homicidio perfecto pues era
una pena de 30 a 50 años y en caso si
era tentado 15 años verdad esas son las
penas desproporcionadas que tienen cada
una de esta mujer que aún están en
cárcel verdad por una condena la cual
pues nosotras como agrupación ciudadana
por la despenalización del aborto no
pudimos llegar al inicio de sus procesos
sin embargo estamos luchando porque a
través de con una sentencia de
conmutaciones de pena verdad de indultos
ellas puedan obtener pues su libertad
y actualmente siempre se sigue
criminalizando bajo esos mismos
parámetros que explicaba morena herrera
que son mujeres que viven en condición
de vulnerabilidad y sobre todo nosotras
consideramos que es por su condición de
género mujer
y el salvador lo hemos dicho tiene una
de las prohibiciones del aborto más
estrictas del mundo y no permite
excepciones ni siquiera por violación o
porque la vida de la madre está en
riesgo y las penas de prisión pueden
extenderse hasta los 40 años en muchos
casos hemos visto que han sido tres
décadas en los últimos años se han
revocado algunos fallos y varias mujeres
han sido liberadas
en su experiencia con este tema algo va
a cambiar en el futuro cercano en el
salvador
actualmente como a nosotras como
abogadas defensoras no se nos da la
tarea y se nos ha dado la tarea hasta la
fecha de poder demostrar la inocencia de
todas estas mujeres con pruebas
científicas que es algo muy importante
sin embargo los sesgos que a veces tiene
el sistema todo el aparataje judicial a
veces impiden que puedan dar una
sentencia conforme a derecho aplicando
la sana crítica verdad en este caso los
jueces que pueden también iniciar un
proceso en el cual se puedan retomarlo
estas mujeres con una una medida verdad
sustitutiva la detención para poder
seguir el proceso mientras se compruebe
su inocencia asimismo también nos hemos
topado con casos verdad que en los
cuales hasta que termine el proceso 22
años verdad ha pasado en ese proceso y
al final se ha logrado y poder
determinar su libertad en este caso fue
de evelyn verdad hernández que pasó más
del tiempo requerido
y ella pues al final se logró su
libertad sin embargo aunque un juez
también establezca una sentencia en la
cual dice cierre del proceso
sobreseimiento provisional o absolución
siempre estamos frente a una fiscalía
que sigue persiguiendo a las mujeres
antes de recursos e interponer recursos
los cuales no tienen fundamento sin
embargo él quieren que siempre sigan
resguardándose verdad en el penal
privada de su libertad acordando ese
proyecto de vida muchísimas gracias a
las dos muy duro documentar estas
realidades como si no fuera suficiente
enfrentar un embarazo con sus cambios y
con sus riesgos normales las mujeres
también tienen que tener miedo de las
consecuencias si ocurre una emergencia
durante la gestación gracias a ustedes
por estar con nosotros en ellas hoy y
sigan en france24
[Música]